la maintenance et le couvre-feu on l'a
dit au début
et quand vous avez appris que c'était le
couvre feu oubliant que vous aviez un
film qui sortait ça vous inspire quoi le
couvre-feu basse et rien que le mot est
très très traumatisant c'est des mots
qu'on entend pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale des choses comme ça je crois
qu'il ya des lensois santé en france
mais c'est en algérie oui voilà c'est
rentrer chez vous vous êtes loi dadt
dehors c'est je pense que c'est
nécessaire au niveau sanitaire matin
effectivement c'est terrible d'avoir
servi de voir ces gens qui sont plus
dehors et où je parle bien de pas bien
sûre d'elle au cinéma cette heure-là
actuellement improbable couvre feu c'est
un beau dramatique je pensais pas
connaître ça pour une fois de mon vivant
je pensais pas connaître les mots au
réchauffement climatique je les
entendais parler mais je connaissais pas
à vivre les conséquences virus épidémie
non plus et c'est à cela qu'on est
surpris par la rapidité claqué tout d'un
coup la nature se retourne contre nous
la nature nous impose un couvre-feu dans
un sursaut de bon sens
ben oui on est forcé de le respecter moi
je pense va pas durer je pense que cet
été les choses vont redevenir normales
alors si ordinaire anormales se relancer
dans cette frénésie consumériste qui
fait fondre la planète
ça serait une catastrophe si vraiment la
conscience est prise de ce qui est en
train de se passer
ben c'est peut-être un
un bien pour un mal même si je dis ça
avec tous les morts qu'il ya eu voilà je
ne souhaite pas peut-être peut-être que
c'est relativement gentil ce qui se
passe par rapport à ce qui pourrait se
passer
qui va peut-être se passer dans les
années à venir peut-être
[Musique]